[Music]
And greetings to you, our Sum TV family.
Welcome to I'd like to know, our Bible
question and answer program. We are so
pleased that you've sharing that you are
sharing a little bit of your no doubt
busy day with us. My name is CA Murray.
I'm in the company of Pastor Steven
Boore and Pastor David Salazar.
Gentlemen, good to have you here to
study the word of God.
>> Amen.
>> Real pleasure.
>> As we say each time, it is our pledge
and our promise as far as we can to give
you your answers from the word of God.
Your questions come from the word of
God. The answers should come from the
self-same place. So that's the pledge we
make to you. If an answer can be found,
we will try to find it and give it to
you as the Bible and as the Lord and as
the Holy Spirit gives it to us. Should
you want to be part of this program, we
encourage you in the strongest terms to
do so by sending your questions to TV at
some summ as in marytv.org.
That's tv.sumtv.org
and we will add your questions to our uh
rather impressive pile and get to them
just as soon as we can. Pastor Salazar,
would you open our program in prayer,
please?
>> Absolutely. Let us pray. Heavenly
Father, as we come before you at this
hour, we thank you for allowing us to
know that we can come to you and ask the
w the wisdom, the knowledge and
understanding of your scriptures.
Because in our own strength, our own
understanding, we are very limited. But
through the influence of the Holy
Spirit, we can receive the light and the
understanding so that we may share the
truth from your word that may point
those who are watching and hearing to
you and to understand what the word of
your of of you really speak to them. We
ask that you will please bless us now as
we are uh opening your word and allow us
to uh say things that are according to
your will. We pray this in Jesus name.
Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question comes
to us from Teresa. I was talking to my
wife last night and she said, "No, it's
Teresa." So, it's Teresa in English.
Teresa in Spanish. Yes. Uh, Teresa, we
hope we didn't tear your name up,
butcher it too badly.
>> I I think I think this is really Theesa
because it has an H after the T.
>> It does indeed.
>> So, if it doesn't have the H, it's
Theesa.
just just a little itsybitsy detail.
>> Very
>> those are the kind of itsybitsy details
my wife gives me at night when we're
talking about things like this. Thank
you very much, pastor. Um, hello pastor.
She says, "I'd like to know if the
Sabbath is only a symbol of the seal and
the Holy Spirit is the actual seal. Is
the Holy Spirit is the Holy Spirit the
seal?" The one text that I brought here
uh and and you guys have several more
was Ephesians uh 4:30 which talks about
do not grieve the Holy Spirit whereby we
are sealed.
>> Um and I know you have you guys have
several more texts but that says to me
that the sealing is the the purview of
the Holy Spirit. It it does the sealing.
So it is the sealer. Um then I've got as
we all have a series of Ellen White
quotes which talk about sealing and uh
the seal and the sign and the Sabbath.
Uh so let me loose you brethren and let
you go so that you can add your flavor
to the to the
>> Sure. Absolutely pastor. Well, I I say I
guess we could mention briefly the two
other parts in the New Testament where
where Apostle Paul speaks of the Holy
Spirit as the sealer or as the one that
presents the the action of sealing
individuals. The first one is also in
Ephesians and it's in Ephesians 1:13
and it says there in him speaking of
Jesus you also trusted after you heard
the word of truth the gospel of your
salvation in whom also having believed
you were sealed with the Holy Spirit of
promise. Mhm.
>> So here is the other part of in the book
of Ephesians where the apostle Paul
speaks that as you believe in Jesus, as
you believe in Christ, you are sealed
with the Holy Spirit of promise. In this
particular verse, you could perhaps be a
little bit, you know, is is it Paul
saying that you are sealed with the Holy
Spirit and the Holy Spirit is the actual
seal. Well, uh, as you mentioned in
Ephesians 4:30, it mentions that that
you are sealed with the Holy Spirit for
the day of redemption, but it's not
necessarily implying the Holy Spirit is
sealed. Now, let's go to second
Corinthians verse chapter 1,
>> and this is the last part in or the last
verse that the Apostle Paul uses the
expression of the Holy Spirit being the
sealer. 2 Corinthians 1 and uh verse 21
and 22
and I have here and it says
now he who establishes us with you in
Christ and has anointed us is God who
also has sealed us and given us the
spirit in our hearts as a guarantee. So
here we have these three verses where it
speaks of we re we are sealed with the
Holy Spirit or we are sealed by the Holy
Spirit and it's really more of the agent
that the Lord uses to place that seal in
our hearts. That's really with what the
verses are more implying than particular
saying the Holy Spirit is the actual
seal. So he's the sealer. uh this is
from what I can understand but we're
going to look into the verses or any
white quotes that kind of confirm this
as well.
You know, uh, several years ago, I wrote
a document, uh, particularly on this
question, whether the spirit is the seal
or whether the Sabbath is the seal. And,
um, you know, I don't know whether I
should offer it online because I get
criticized here because there are so
many requests. But, um, I'll just go
ahead and say that if you would like to
have a copy of that, uh, study, which is
probably close to 20 pages, Mhm.
>> with quotations from the spirit of
prophecy and from the Bible. We'll be
glad to send it to you. Um just let me
give you three examples
of the relationship between the internal
and the external.
The Holy Spirit is the internal seal.
>> But it is manifested by an external act.
>> True. Agreed.
>> For example,
circumcision.
God told the Israelites to circum be
circumcised. That was a physical act, an
external act. But the meaning behind it
was that God wanted to circumcise the
heart. Right?
>> Now, I could give verses. The verses are
in this document. So, let me ask you
this. Is the seal internal or external?
>> The answer is yes.
>> It's a sign, an external sign of an
internal experience.
>> Right? Another example, baptism. It's an
external act.
>> Yes.
>> But it's a sign, a visible sign that
you've given your heart to the Lord and
that you now are integrated into God's
family.
>> Internal experience manifested in
external act. Communion.
>> We partake a little piece of bread and a
little a little uh flask of grape juice.
It's an external act,
but it has an internal meaning
>> which means that we are recognizing that
we are sinners and that that Christ by
his broken body and by his blood has
saved us from sin.
>> Amen.
>> It's an internal experience that is
manifested in an external uh act. Mhm.
>> Now, the 7th Adventist Church believes
that at the end of time, God is going to
pour out his spirit in latter rain
power.
>> Mhm.
>> That is an internal experience.
>> Right.
>> But how is it exhibited?
It is exhibited in the observance of the
Sabbath of the seventh day Sabbath. The
external act
>> which is an indication
>> that we have been sealed by the Holy
Spirit. Amen.
>> So to say that there's a contradiction
between saying it's the spirit or it's
the Sabbath
>> is simply not true
>> because the observance of the Sabbath is
the visible manifestation that we are
serving the creator God.
>> Amen.
>> And so uh there's no contradiction
between the Holy Spirit being the sealer
or the seal and the Sabbath being the
seal. Mhm.
>> Interestingly enough, as you mentioned,
pastor, the Holy Spirit works as the one
that seals our heart. I mean, we receive
that
that power of God to obey and to be able
to have the outward experience of having
the Sabbath and keeping the Sabbath
correctly, holy, uh obviously is not
just an external keeping of the Sabbath
in the sense of just outwardly doing
that. Uh it's really the combination of
both God's sealing and the spirit of
prophecy mentions that the you know
receiving the seal it's a settling into
the truth or the ceilings are settling
into the truth. In other words that
you're not going to be moved from f
following and fulfilling the the law of
God in your heart in your life. So you
will obey by love but also with a
true surrendering and a complete
dedication to honoring God in everything
that you do. So the character of God can
also be revealed by having that
experience of the ceiling in our hearts.
You are a reflection of Christ following
his commandments.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Jesus said by their fruits
>> you shall know them.
>> You shall know them. Mhm.
>> So the Does the spirit have fruit?
>> Absolutely.
>> How do you know that you have the Holy
Spirit?
>> You have to have fruits
>> because there's fruit.
>> Visible fruit.
>> Yes.
>> And so the same is true. How do you know
that you're honoring the creator?
>> By keeping his holy Sabbath. Amen. The
external act is a manifestation of an
internal commitment to the Lord.
>> Even at the risk of death during the
little time of trouble. Yeah. The
commitment is of the heart is so great
that the person is going to be willing
to die to observe externally the
Sabbath.
>> Amen. One line from um u eight
testimonies. The sign or seal of God is
revealed. And that's what you're saying.
It's revealed. It's there. It just shows
itself
>> in the observance of the seventh day
Sabbath.
>> Beautiful quotation.
>> Yeah. The Lord's memorial of of
Christian. So it's it's there. It's
revealed. Now, we need to just make a
slight little left turn because there's
one one ceiling when you come to the
Lord and you step under the banner of
Jesus Christ. You you you have signed on
to to Christianity. Christ is in your
life. So, you you are sealed. You belong
to him. And then that and that's an
early reign experience. And then there's
a little something different, maybe a
lot something different at the end when
we are sealed.
>> Uh walk us through that, pastor. Well,
you know, um, we have the early reign
and the latter reign.
>> When a person is converted to Christ and
is baptized, they receive the early
reign. Correct. The Holy Spirit.
>> The Apostle the Apostle Peter on his in
his sermon on the day of Pentecost says,
"Repent for the forgiveness of sins, and
you will receive the gift of the Holy
Spirit."
>> Yes.
>> So, in the early reign experience, when
you're baptized, you receive the Holy
Spirit besides the forgiveness of sins.
Mhm.
>> At the end of the Christian
dispensation,
once again, you are going to have
rain.
>> Mhm.
>> Spiritually speaking, but it's the
latter rain.
And the latter reign uh the the the seal
that is visible is the observance of the
seventh day Sabbath because you have a
heart relationship with Christ.
>> Yes. You know, the the problem with the
Jews in Christ day
>> is they kept the external Sabbath, but
it was not the result of the Holy Spirit
being in their heart.
>> Of course,
>> uh so we're not saying that the keeping
the Sabbath is a sign unless you have a
heart commitment to Jesus Christ and the
observance of the Sabbath is the natural
outflow of having Christ in the heart.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. I mean, and this is I think that
is important. Maybe we can give
reference to there is in in the last day
events. I know it's a compilation of
many quotes but there is a section there
that is called the seal of god and the
mark of the beast. That's chapter 15.
And and you'll see there many quotes
where uh sister white mentions that the
fourth commandment alone of all ten
contain the seal of the great lawgiver
the creator of the heavens and the
earth. speaking of the Sabbath as as a
symbol of the seal or as a seal of God.
But again is is really is really as you
were mentioning pastor it's a it's it's
a external experience of what's
happening in the heart. Uh and if
somebody was to say oh this the seal is
only the Holy Spirit. Well, then how
would you be able to tell if you really
have received the Holy Spirit and that
seal? It has to be it has to come with
that decision and that conversion and
conviction that you have to keep the law
of God holy and including the fourth
commandment which will become the center
stage of the last conflict. So therefore
it is imperative that we understand that
those uh two uh concepts are are really
you know one and the same. You are
receive the seal of the Holy Spirit and
you keep the Sabbath as an external
experience of that sealing in your
heart.
>> You know the the the fourth commandment
is so crucial and we wonder why do you
put such emphasis on the fourth
commandment?
>> God identifies himself in the fourth
commandment.
>> Truly, if you look at the ten
commandments, you wouldn't really
technically know who's writing this
stuff until you get number four. You
know,
>> honor thy father and her mother. Thou
shalt not kill. Thou shall not steal.
Where's this coming from? you know,
well, it's coming from the God who signs
his name in the fourth commandment. So,
when he he chooses to make that, dare I
say, an issue of of salvation, it's
legitimate because it he identifies
himself and your keeping of that shows
that you identify with him.
>> Uh, and that you cannot get around. Um,
I'll use an an old Obamacare statement
from the Affordable Care Act. There has
to be a pre-existing condition and that
pre-existing condition is that your
heart is right with the Lord and if your
heart is right your head will be right
and your actions will will follow. Mhm.
>> You know, and I had someone once uh say
some a Sunday keeper say to me, um, "You
Adventist, you believe that God is going
to test the whole world with a day?"
And I looked at him and I said, "Well,
God tested Adam and Eve with a tree."
>> Right.
>> So, so the Sabbath is simply the visible
test of your commitment to the Lord.
>> Right.
>> And Adam and Eve, if they obtain abstain
from eating from the tree, it was a sign
that their allegiance was to God.
>> Yes. God has all kinds of external signs
which are the sign of an internal
experience.
>> Amen.
>> Well done gentlemen. Um we go on now to
Elizabeth
uh no location but we do thank Elizabeth
for her question. I am looking for some
guidance now on developing a
presentation of practical ways to
prepare for the little time of trouble.
When exactly should we flee the cities?
Should we be doing any canning, freezing
etc. uh for that time? I am talking
specifically for the time between the
national Sunday law and the close of
probation. I know many people are
interested in this. We have lots of
information on how to prepare our hearts
etc. But uh but about help for practical
living in this time, do you have
anything? And of course, she thanks us
in advance.
Well, basically Matthew chapter 24, if
we can go there just for a minute,
>> Matthew 24 mentions two tribulations.
>> And as I've mentioned many times,
Matthew 24 is in chronological order.
>> Yes.
>> In other words, one event follows the
other in chronological order. Um, the
first time of trouble uh or tribulation
is what we call the little time of
trouble.
>> It's before the close of probation,
>> right? shortly before the close of
probation when the Sabbath is being
proclaimed fully according to the spirit
of prophecy.
>> Now, what is going to precipitate that
little time of trouble? Well, Matthew 24
tells us in verse 6, "And you will hear
of wars and rumors of wars. See that you
are not troubled, for all these things
must come to pass, but the end is not
yet. Nation will rise against nation and
kingdom against kingdom. There will be
famines, pestilences, and earthquakes in
various places. And then it says in
verse eight, all these are the beginning
of sorrows.
>> And then the very next verse begins with
the word then.
>> Then yeah,
>> which in Greek always refers to an event
that happens after another event. So
these so-called natural disasters are
related to what we find in verse 9.
>> Verse 9 is going to tell us what the
result is going to be. God's people are
going to be blamed
>> because it says then they will deliver
you up to tribulation and kill you.
There will be martyrs during this
period, not after the close of
probation.
>> So it say they will kill you and you
will be hated by all nations for my
name's sake. So that's the little time
of trouble that uh Elizabeth is
referring to here. uh Ellen White uh
strongly urged
uh God's followers to live in the
country
>> to find a place in the country. By the
way, that's the reason why Secrets
Unsealed is in the process
>> uh of transferring to the country.
People ask us, you know, um how is the
project going? Well, they think that uh
we're going to start building the day
after we bought the property. Well, it
doesn't work that way because there were
no wells, there were no buildings, uh
you have to get permits, there's a whole
process. You have to get solar panels.
We're doing all of that uh because we
believe that the spirit of prophecy
counsels us that we should move to the
country.
>> Uh individually, we should also try and
find a place in the country. And she
gives several prescriptions not far too
far from the city that you can't go in
and witness to the city. That's one
thing she mentions a place where you can
produce your own food.
>> Mhm.
>> Where you have a supply of water,
>> right?
>> Where you can be self-contained. In
other words,
>> that is preparation for the little time
of trouble.
When the big time of trouble comes,
>> there's nothing
>> that's not going to happen.
>> Yeah. because God's people are going to
be fleeing.
>> Um, you know, it says when you see the
abomination of desolation, which I've
shown in the Matthew 24 series, it's uh
it's the Sunday law. Uh, it says flee.
>> Mhm.
>> And then it says, "Pray that your flight
might not be on the Sabbath." That's
significant.
>> Yeah.
>> Absolutely.
>> In other words, those who are fleeing
are Sabbathkeepers.
>> And then, um, probation closes. And in
verse 21, then you have the great
tribute. It's qualified with an
adjective.
>> Yes.
>> It says, "For then," notice, "then then,
there will be great tribulation, such as
not has been since the beginning of the
world until this time, no, nor ever
shall be." In other words, there's not
going to be a tribulation worse than
this one. It has to be the time of
Jacob's trouble,
>> right?
>> Uh during that time, it won't do us any
good to have food, provision,
everything, because God's people are
going to have to flee.
>> Thank you. Uh so so you know when you
when you speak of in practical terms you
have here canning freezing for that time
etc. fleeing the cities
you know uh we should ma be making
preparations to be able to do that right
particularly as we see the signs of the
times that are taking place in the world
today. Um so in practical terms if it's
possible move to the country where uh
Ellen White uh gives the the parameters
or the details about how to prepare once
we live in the country you have to learn
to live in the country by the way it's
not a case of you know I remember when
you probably don't remember Y2K
>> I do
>> everybody everybody you know there were
people in the United States who went
back to their countries in Latin America
because the crisis is going going to be
in the begin in the US and you know they
they sold all of their stuff here in the
United States and they moved down there
and and then nothing happened and and
they were lamenting they were say oh why
did we do this you know it's not a
question of acting in panic
>> it's something that takes time and
preparation and calculation
>> and you have to be very um you know wise
in not as you mentioned not being you
know just moving out of fear, out of
excitement. Even you have to think, plan
in a way where you are able to
>> if you live to the move to the country,
you're either learning to be able to
sustain your family while you live in
the country or find a way to maybe start
your own job or your own business in a
sense so you can keep your life and and
as you're learning and transitioning. I
think that the practical way that we
can, you know, also do is learn to do
things on your own. start to start to
depend on your own understanding. Maybe
you don't know many things, how to solve
things. Well, there's a lot of videos of
do-it-yourselves uh you know how to help
you know do the soil, how to repair
plumbing, electrical things in your
home, you have to learn to be relying on
the abilities and the talents that has
given you. And this is part of the the
practical way of preparing for that
time. Uh you need to learn how to
cultivate what works in your area where
you live and so on forth. So I think
that there's a lot of things that
practically you can do and you can learn
and apply. Uh God give you will give you
that opportunity. Uh but again don't
move out of fear, out of desperation,
out of excitement. Follow wisdom, follow
counsel and be um wise in your moving
and following these along. uh because as
you have said pastor there's many many
people who have left to the country and
have no clue what to do there and they
have left their jobs and they have no
way to sustain their families and then
they return with a failure. So we have
to be very careful in this process
>> and some people say you know h how is it
that you're going to flee any place the
government can find you anywhere
>> you know with the technology that they
have uh God can block the technology
last I knew.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. uh you know,
we're going to have to trust in the
Lord. You can The thing is we we tend
not to like to to surrender control. You
know, if I pack and I plan and I put a a
food basket away, well, there this is a
time of trouble for which there is no
parallel,
>> right?
>> So, so you you your planning may go up
in smoke. You have to just trust in the
Lord. Amen. That he will deliver that.
He who fed the children of Israel in the
in the desert can feed his people down
to the end of time. You may have to just
lean upon the Lord because all of your
provisions may be gone. Again, our time
has fast loops into eternity. Thank you
for sharing your time with us. We'll see
you again soon and God bless.
[Music]